do you know who you welcomed into your  home  [Music]  we and we embrace it mrs. Ternan  hi I'm Shawn pleased to meet you mr.  Turner well here the beautiful home she  is a godsend  I was expecting someone older less weird  we hope you'll treat our house is your  home I'm sure you and Jericho will from  an instant bond  [Music]  she's cool with everything she knows the  situation I guess we should talk about  this she's gone you can put the dog down  I'm fine as I am mr. Jenner  you lost Jericho when he was 13 weeks  Darth who took it hard this is the only  thing that brought her back  I should take Jericho for a walk now  [Applause]  you hired a nanny for a doll did you  find her she is wonderful with Jericho  and if my baby twists her so do i how  much did those boys tell you about what  happened what if she wakes up  what if she remembers  [Music]  do you know who you welcomed into your  home  [Music]  you